foreign
let's go out to Arkansas and talk to
Holly what's up Holly
yes how are you
sometimes when people are like John I
like to yell my first name too John it's
so cute
what's up
of course thanks for calling sorry for
hanging up on you earlier what's up it's
okay well I was
I was on something
[Laughter]
let's just see how it goes you know what
that's probably the wisest response of
any caller ever so what's up what's up
well I need some help getting my husband
says to my son or about his ADHD
behaviors when he's frustrated with him
um you're getting on to my business now
Holly well it's my world too that's in
my soul is this kid his son also yes
okay so it's it's y'all's kid yes our
child I want you to know that just as
the call is starting your language is
very instructive
and I'll tell you why in a minute that's
really important but go ahead okay I
won't interrupt you anymore go ahead
okay well
because I also have ADHD
okay maybe not go ahead um but he's one
of those be tougher you know we just if
he didn't spank him this would end and
uh uh I just we've got to get on the
same page but I kind of feel like we're
not even in the same library
and I'm kind of stuck on this one so
when you say
oh man
okay I've got to say this first because
it's just
burning a hole in my chest and then I'm
gonna Circle back okay
for your husband for everybody listening
you cannot beat ADHD out of a human
being
you can't hit them
you can't spank them or whatever word
you want to use
for beating your child but you cannot
beat ADHD out of a kit
period end of discussion
foreign
so I needed to say that out loud all
right let's Circle back um when you say
your husband's struggling with his ADHD
behaviors walk me through what are some
things that frustrate what I mean what
are some things that are hard to live
with with an ADHD kit
well he my husband's super not 8
a structured routine
and my son is a forgetful distracted
impulsive
um you know forgets to where his shoes
are
um
doesn't hear the first you know a couple
times you ask him to do something he may
not but it didn't go in
um
just those typical things he's not out
of control or you know getting in
trouble at school or anything like that
it's just
um at home it's very hard for my husband
to understand
the world of an ADHD person because he
is so
regimented and
opposite
um
so this isn't what you're asking but I'm
going to put this out there as as a as a
point of reference ADHD is a complicated
thing but ultimately the the best way
I've heard it distilled down by the
great Gabor mate is
ADHD is a body's long-term response to
chaos
it's a disconnection
okay and there is even some evidence
according to Dr mate that that's that
begins in utero in some cases okay so
also
an over obsession
with routine and this is the way this
should be and this is the way this has
to be
can also be a body's way of trying to
create control out of Chaos
so I want to frame what's going on in
your home it may be two sides of the
same coin
okay
and you know this better than anybody
because as you said you've lived with
this your whole life
the thing that your son needs more than
anything in the world
as a starting point
is to know beyond a shadow of a doubt
that his dad loves him
not how he performs not how he gets
everything right and in the perfect
order but that his dad loves him
and that my friend is the place from
which the other behaviors can be
constructed because I'm also not one of
these guys that lets ADHD kid just run
amok that's nonsense too they don't like
that life either I didn't like that life
I still don't like that life I still
need High accountability
but it has to start from a place of
there's like I'm there will be no bigger
fan in your life than your dad period
and Mom is going to have to hold Sun
accountable too right so
um
here's what I see sometimes not
sometimes often I see one of a couple of
things one
dad is
got too much going on in his own life
and so the thoughtful patient practice
that is parenting is frustrating because
he in his mind and body he doesn't have
time for it that's number one or
there are parents who see any sort of
forgetfulness as
disrespect as lazy
because they also see ADHD Kids Laser in
on Legos or laser in on a on a video
game or laser in on writing a novel
right and so they say if you can do it
there you can do it here right or the is
that your house yes okay all right well
in all those dinosaur names why can you
remember that yeah
there you go man
and and that usually leads to the third
thing which is
moms and dads everybody we all do it
um we use our kids Behavior as some sort
of scorecard for how we're doing as as
adults
and if my kid can't put his shoes away
that means I'm failing and I'll be
damned if I'm gonna fail
does that sound that sounds right
yes okay I see there's this head shake
and this um
look of defeat on my husband's face
sometimes when looking at him just like
like how like he's throwing his hands up
like I just I don't I don't know what to
do yeah and you you know this because
this was you as a kid yes that yes but
you know that there is no worse feeling
being an ADHD kid and feeling like you
just failed your adults to the point the
adults quit on you
yes
it's it's collapsing
which then sends the body off careening
trying to solve for the chaos and the
whole system Loops back up except it
Loops a little bit faster and a little
bit faster and a little bit faster
because that body's telling that kid hey
because of you you ran Dad off
and that that's when my son goes in for
the physical
because he wants the hugs and the
holding and the you know
that's his I guess way to no no that's
that's going back to yeah what I said a
few minutes ago the number one thing a
kid with ADHD has to know is the adults
in his life will go to hell for him
they will fight for that kid no matter
what and they love that kid no matter
what and that does include a ton of
touch especially from Dad
and from there we can have conversations
about choices and conversations about
upstream and conversations about getting
enough sleep and getting off screens and
some of those things that
um I've seen anecdotally and I think the
literature is it's kind of mixed but I
don't trust some of that literature
these days
um
the exacerbates ADHD I know sleep for
sure and I know diet for sure
um but some of those things Upstream
right and you know
when you get a full night's sleep or
when your son gets a full night's sleep
the morning's different we all know
those things yes but man it's tough to
get a kid to go to sleep when he feels
like he's trying to fend off or or make
his dad feel better
which isn't his job so here's the hard
part about this call this call is best
had between me and your husband not
between me and you
I know no I've gone to therapy to work
on mine
not a feelings guy I don't give a crap
about that he is a feelings guy he just
has a very sophisticated mechanism for
shutting that stuff system down oh yeah
and he knows I mean he's I've talked
about how he probably has PTSD and he's
like well doesn't everybody have
something and just is he a vet a veteran
well he grew up in Southwest Little Rock
when
he's got a lot of hardened
stuff there so here's
ugh
can I I've read scattered and I've told
him you know if you would listen to it
or read it or something it would help
him understand he just he kind of looks
at me like I'm an alien and okay so
here's here's here's where we have to go
from here okay
um
and I and you know what I'm about to say
but me saying it out loud is going to be
very hard to hear okay
and I know I just kind of talked out of
both sides of my mouth but both things
can be true at the same time
um this is a very generalized
Neanderthal way of looking at things all
right but in the grand scheme or in the
in the anthropological sense if you will
it's mom's job to Circle up and protect
young kids
and it's Dad's job to protect the system
okay the unit all right now we're in the
21st century and most of us work on
computers I realize life is different
there's not people chasing us with clubs
but
I just paint that picture for this
reason
there comes a moment
when if your husband or your wife
depending on who's listening to this is
hurting your child
the other parent has to step in
and stepping in looks different for
everybody and I'm very reluctant to give
somebody their or what
statement that's something that is very
personal
but at the end of the day your husband
is choosing you handed him the road map
which is the book by Dr mate you handed
him that road map I don't know of a
better book
and if I was sitting there with my son
and I've had these moments in these
Seasons when I don't feel like I don't
like he's talking Spanish and I'm
talking like
I don't know Swahili and we are on
different planets we're not even talking
the same we're not everyone we're so
disconnected and somebody handed me a
map back to my son you better believe
that'd be everything else in my life
would stop
and so in a strange way your husband is
choosing misery and he's choosing to
have a broken relationship with the son
not to head to Healing
he's also choosing to have a broken
relationship with his wife because
you've asked him to go to counseling
with you you've asked him to be a part
of healing the family unit and building
something new and he's looked at you and
said no
and that puts you on an island to either
watch this continue with your son and
let this thing continue on in another
family system and yet another family
system or you step in and say this ends
with me and my son
what is that what does that look like in
real life
that looks like you when there's no
fighting and you've heard me say this a
thousand times on the show not in the
middle of a fight because that me lines
are drawn at that point
this is you saying Hey I want to go out
and you telling your husband I
want you and our son to have a great
relationship and my son needs his dad
and right now my son is a drill sergeant
or my dad my son has somebody who's
really frustrated with him and he has
the the distinct impression that his dad
doesn't like him much less love him
would you be willing to try something
else
because what we're doing is not working
he's not finding his shoes he's not
suddenly making his bed
and more more volume
more hitting More film that's those
aren't working will you be willing to
try something else
and I I'm I'm trying to intentionally
make this about an offer of
I want your life to be better too
because here's the deal your husband
doesn't want to have a bad relationship
with his son he's out of tool he's out
of tools right he loves that point yes
he loves that boy very much he just
keeps reaching into his tool kit and he
only has a screwdriver that's it
correct and quite honestly I bet his dad
had no Tools in his toolkit right
probably not so he's trying right and
I'd love that
I love dad says all the time I see I see
him in me because his dad's like super
soft guy now but he'll say I see I see
him or me and him all the time
does he like that or is he trying to
avoid that
my husband
well I mean my my father-in-law says
that about my husband he'll say you know
I used to be like that and now he's you
know he's different he's retired he's
looking back on everything and
so I don't that surprises me because he
is so
such a soft guy I I know many many many
men
who look back
and say man I would have done that
differently and sometimes it's I would
have kicked my kid out of my basement
right I let my kid play way too many
video games and I would have had his
butt in a gym I would have had his butt
out of the house I would have signed him
up for Stuff
and also
there's a lot of dads that look back and
say my God what did I do
I tried to beat love into my child
I tried to beat mental illness out of
them I tried to yell and kick and scream
peace into their heart
and I tried to get a kid to make sure
that I wasn't mad and that was never the
kid's job
man that's a common regret
a really common regret so I want to
honor the fact that your husband loves
your son I know that I also benefited
greatly from having a wife
that said no more
because I was really frustrated when my
kid was two when my kid was three and my
kid was four I didn't know what I was
doing
and I had a wife that said this has to
stop
and it wasn't bad or egregious or
anything like that but it was I need to
get some new skills
and I would put my relationship up with
my son over anybody's
it's pretty powerful here's here's
healing in 101 for ADHD something as
simple as how old your kid
10 10 yeah
perfect
I can't tell you the Magic in my home
um again I don't
not talking about my son's Diagnostics
or anything like that and having
Diagnostics
um
that they start a weekly breakfast
together and they just go talk and they
hang out
that they
play and wrestle together
that
we're practicing so when your kid
forgets his shoes cool
let's go find the shoes
and if you choose to not know where your
shoes are then you're choosing to not go
fishing man because we only have this
much time to go fishing
and there's one or two times we cancel
the fishing trip and it's a bummer for
everybody
but we can't go fishing without shoes
and kids learn Upstream about choices
and learn upstream and it's not this
panic and this yelling and this oh my
gosh dad's gonna be so mad my kids know
they really really can't make me mad
because I don't give them that power
all of this is creating a peaceful home
so that the kid whose body is over fired
up all the time can actually function
just turns the music down on everything
and you've experienced that right
yes yeah
I'm sorry that you have to watch this
because I know it's hard to watch
it is it's especially when I know
because a lot of it is I know what to do
but I kind of like to structure and
follow through with some of it because I
get you know distracted and it may
really be important for you to work
well if you've got a chaotic home
because my I guarantee you you and I
could have another two or three phone
calls because this isn't the only thing
going on in your house I know
yeah well this is we've worked on I mean
because like I said I've gone to therapy
and worked through a lot of things and
uh thank goodness Dave Ramsey found his
way into my husband's ear several years
ago on the deer stand and so we don't
have money fights anymore
um so this really is kind of the last
but you're right there are several other
layers that kind of come back to this
um well if he would have the courage I
would love to talk to him and with a
spirit of love and a spirit of hey man
there's a different way to do this
and this isn't me wanting to fight
anybody and I have no interest in
fighting anybody but I do want
dads to learn new tools for how to love
their sons
and I want parents both moms and dads to
have new tools to create households so
that their kids can be successful
and we've just had a generation of kids
that we thought we'd just get louder and
get more angry and more raged out and
that would work and look around guys
it's not working it's not
and
for the Bro Downs listening to the show
no I'm not talking about not holding
kids accountable accountability is a
Cornerstone
no I'm not talking about getting rid of
consequences are you kidding me
consequences are critical
but I'm also talking about 10 year olds
10. six
four twelve
moms and dads we can do better
thank you for the call Holly I'll be oh
man I'll be here for you guys holler at
me anytime I can help